who pilot the [ __ ] Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier what is your
transmission my transmission is [ __ ]
death he understand me I can't see out
here I got a bag of wreaths I got a big
dick and a magician's hat
greetings on the Lord's Day you bad
[ __ ] jonquil Joey in full
effect [ __ ]
aka a man of many reefers we got the
mints
we got the Skywalker we got the Black
Label the other one went down was a long
[ __ ] weekend you understand me
but that's all over now humble Joey's
here to check out my new book some a
sure as usual you get the day [ __ ] it
started on the right foot you know made
God why [ __ ] around with the other
let's open up with the black canister of
debt just to get the [ __ ] Sunday
spotless we go on Sundays you know I'm
doing time my wife and the baby went to
church they've got a little [ __ ]
Church with Gentiles over here or catch
the early morning with the cap that you
don't may go have a stale all to [ __ ]
that perverts then I'm gonna [ __ ]
shits on the cool kettlebells I'm hook
up at the family have a little lunch
I'm gonna meet my man riding I gotta
write some Joseph's [ __ ] special you
don't saying you want the special would
be good they have to put some [ __ ]
[ __ ] together and then that said it's
nothing but R&R and it's the Lord's Day
but listen enough with me I spoke about
[ __ ] really understand because that's
the [ __ ] conversation today are you
gonna smoke reefer and how it's going to
affect your seven-day you found
like that that's how it's gonna [ __ ]
affect he understand you don't need blow
porches you don't need nothing a pipe a
[ __ ] meal and the best refrain
[ __ ] Southern California that's how I
do it nice and simple no drama you don't
need nothing you know how these people
wanna know my cousin learned I don't
give a [ __ ] about your cousin I give a
[ __ ] about you today the Church of
what's happened now today what's going
on right now
there you go you'll smoke for your
[ __ ] to get up happiness
Autobots now from yesterday you're still
recovering from the [ __ ] Hillary
speech and you ship together right don't
trust nobody don't trust none of these
[ __ ] was last type of politician
took you out to dinner but you [ __ ]
lunch when you need to get [ __ ] together
stop [ __ ] trying to be like everybody
else to believe any [ __ ] jumping up in
them you gotta have your own [ __ ]
mind gonna get to that main takuya
that's the most important thing what is
it man what has he got if not himself
that he's got not to say the things he
truly feels and not the words of these
[ __ ] much munille because that's what
they do they just meal huh you want me
to get that I'll get a hat what does it
take to be cool a tattoo on my shoulder
what get the [ __ ] out of here
it takes cop and [ __ ] balls and
mother [ __ ] town all these [ __ ] to
suck my dick when it's [ __ ] beat time
dr. police is breathing clears it up
I see see how nice it is we get together
we had a little [ __ ] stoned and that's
it we start the day off on the right
foot I make a little protein shake I put
my little [ __ ] D on my little Raschi
pool I go to war cattle belfry
hyperventilate think I'm getting a heart
attack and I might want you Jitsu it's a
little easier for me you found me
amen I'm an old man I'm a fat [ __ ]
coworker from both [ __ ] eggs
understand me
listen I'm 53 all right I got once with
a great one a banana peel right right
now it ain't over till the fat lady
sings she bust my limo right now just
bring her [ __ ] throat but she gotta
[ __ ] my stick a hot pool in my [ __ ]
eye understand me
I got a fat [ __ ] hot a fat [ __ ]
bad night sex [ __ ] never had days
over I've saved it [ __ ] four or
five times a week smoke me even when I'm
mainly I'm gonna be out here with you
[ __ ] the one wipe what what
it's a weird life guys but you know what
it's an adventure every day it's a
[ __ ] journey what do you give a [ __ ]
about somebody else's journey you're
trying to build your own you follow me
you want to go to Argentina got a
[ __ ] plan who gives a [ __ ] put your
[ __ ] out who gives a [ __ ] if it makes
you happy that's all I give a [ __ ] about
the understand let's go for one walk
sometimes you get too high but once you
open up that door you gotta close it
again
if you open up that door you gotta close
they're not people let their go enjoy
what the [ __ ] it was a nice story but
you let that [ __ ] dog you know the
podcast of the whole afternoon thank you
o'clock Wednesday I'm not sure yet I got
to [ __ ] up like something the Black
Horse saloon and Reseda on Tuesday night
I got my man [ __ ] flap this Thursday
night but yoohoo room 50 people is all
parted in all expectations tour baby you
got no expectations' to and you got the
[ __ ] savage that tore the savage that
tour is on Saturday in Oklahoma and then
the following week in Denver Colorado at
the [ __ ] comedy Worth [ __ ]
but there no expectations to was just a
tape recorder me and you [ __ ]
judging me that's just us we do we throw
to pause right now you understand I'm
like a Vietnam vet my half a [ __ ] I'm
second and take a side down but I'm
shooting [ __ ] ever yet know if
I want me
I mean
if you can't pull this for your family
who can do but L know and in my life if
I can't do this with my family what type
of [ __ ] dude would I be especially in
the Lord today we'll [ __ ] all you right
sends you a little [ __ ] notice and
sis let's park the [ __ ] number who
you hopeful [ __ ] Joey that's why
because I love you Johnson but as you
get don't slow down a little stomach a
matter nobody I'm gonna have to make
this protein shake up to replenish my
[ __ ] and that's it that's it and that's
that you're gonna be around this almond
I'm gonna wash my [ __ ] I'm gonna make a
[ __ ] protein drink coming with
mammoth and then I'm gonna [ __ ] weed
school no I'm gonna go to Leafs go first
so I go to the gym the weeds dry and
you're finally saying what if I take it
they'll enjoy bananas so when I get home
now I gotta get to wash my [ __ ] but my
weights already nice and dry from the to
our [ __ ] weight if I don't if I
wouldn't be on top that would be a
[ __ ] down you tell me what type of
[ __ ] mutt would you think that'd be
anyway I love you [ __ ] with all
my heart
stay black keep me posted have a great
day with your [ __ ] respective
families and keep your eye on Michael
gives a [ __ ] about your little [ __ ]
phone and peanut you Sanctum man made of
Hilary with the rain boots on who gives
a [ __ ] if you like together guac that
sling dick and never [ __ ] stay hid oh
yeah they've el mañana all right I love
you guys